[Music]
welcome back to CBS this morning
Saturday we begin this half-hour with a
quick thinking five-year-old helps
rescue his family from their burning
home Mireya Villarreal is in Georgia
with a young hero is being honored this
is how the Bartow County Fire Department
celebrates a hero five year-old Noah
woods received the full honors for his
quick action early Sunday morning
weren't you scared with the fire and the
smoke around you Wow the electrical fire
broke out in a room Noah shared with his
two-year-old sister Lily that's when
Noah jumped into action what did you do
oh my baby sister he got Lilly and their
dog to safety by climbing out a window
then ran to a neighbor's house to get
help rescuing the rest of his family
still inside the Kingston Georgia home
they were asleep at the time so they had
no idea the house was on fire
so his quick and brave acts would save
the entire family you always wanted to
be a superhero but now he says he wants
to be a police officer
are you happy everyone's okay yeah news
of Noah's heroics have reached the
governor's office in Georgia he is
actually being invited with his family
down to the state capitol where the
Senate will honor him for his bravery
very soon for CBS this morning Saturday
Media VL in Kingston Georgia brother I
whisk you my sister my little girl got a
lesson to all of us yeah
you